health statistics have dictated our
lives for 16 months but in the current
context of high cases
low deaths and rolled back restrictions
how are we feeling and behaving
how are business is faring and can we
point to any lasting
changes so firstly let's look at
consumer behavior now this
shows the number of daily flights across
the year so 2019
at the top 2020 in red and 2021 that
yellow line
you can see there now last week the
number of flights rose to their highest
levels
since before lockdown one evidence
perhaps of travel rules relaxing
and confidence building but we're still
a long way off those 2019 levels
so what about in an area of life where
there are no longer any restrictions at
all
now this shows retail footfall going
back across the entire pandemic
you can see it has recovered to a degree
but it was still 70 77 lower
uh this week than it was in the same
week in 2019.
it's hard to tell how much of that is
caution and how much of it is habits
having permanently changed
so what about the world of business
we've heard a lot haven't we about the
strains
of the pandemic but there are some other
more structural changes going on as well
one of them is a big lack of staff now
this shows the number of job vacancies
going back to decades you can see how
they slumped when the pandemic hit
but they've recovered they're now higher
than they were pre-pandemic
in fact they're higher than they've been
at any point in the last 20 years
it's really quite surprising given that
the economy is recovering from this huge
shock things are particularly bad in
sectors like transport and logistics
this shows the number of online job
adverts
this year compared with the last two
years and look those adverts
up over 300 on what they were in
february 2020.
so why well there's likely a number of
things going on but one of them
is certainly this the latest numbers
show that in early july somewhere
between one
and one and a half million people were
still on furlough
that's a huge number given that the
economy is now officially reopened
and the schemes starting to taper off
and it's not clear yet what happens to
those people
wants that scheme ends and amongst all
of this we have to ask how people are
feeling about these ongoing rules this
might give us a bit of a clue
it shows how people in different age
groups are sticking to isolation rules
and if you look over here a falling
number of the over 35s are indeed doing
that in fact
only 75 did so in the first week in july
it's perhaps one of the best senses we
have of how people are interpreting
and responding to that health data
namely the fact that hospitalizations
and deaths remain low